NITIN MOTGI: Welcome, everyone,
to the Real-World Data
Integration Patterns
on Google Cloud.
My name is Nitin Motgi.
And I'm a product manager in
data analytics [INAUDIBLE]..
So before we get started on the
patterns of data integration
in Google Cloud, let's look
at what the traditional view
of data integration is.
This traditional view of data
integration-- data integration
is such a prevalent
capability that
exists across of the wide
variety of industries.
And it's used horizontally in
various different applications.
From a data perspective, what
data integration provides
is a one-stop shop for
handling a batch of data.
And it does provide, as the
word was "batch" originally,
so it does provide a robust
batch handling of the data.
It has a hardened
orchestration capabilities.
And most important of
all, it has a wide variety
of connectors.
Whether you are connecting
it to the filers, mainframes,
whether you're connecting
talking to databases
or warehouses, a wide
variety of connectors
exists, not only in terms
of [INAUDIBLE] systems
they can connect to but also
various different formats that
can be processed
using these tools.
So the best thing about a
data integration solution
are the utility of the
tool that provides it is
the user-friendly environment.
All of the data
integration tools
provide you a user interface, a
visual development environment
for building these pipelines.
You can think about
any tool that you
take from a data
integration perspective
has that studio,
which can be used
for building ETL pipelines.
And that is, you
can drag and drop.
You can drop different
components in there
and figure out them.
And there you go.
You have a much easier
way of moving data around.
And the one thing
that is very clear,
after looking at being in this
industry for quite some time
now, is they are optimized.
What I find is they
are more optimized
for on-prem environment.
An on-prem environment, it's
varied from a fixed processing
capability.
And then you look at it-- the
amount of optimization that
goes in essentially--
and amount of data
that you can handle.
It's very much controlled and
limited in some sense, right?
But what is happening
is in the era of cloud,
data integration still
plays a very vital role.
There are a lot of benefits
that data integration provides.
And then the thing is,
it enables businesses
to have various different--
[INAUDIBLE] enable
various different aspects
of the business.
One thing I would
like to talk about
is faster time to insights.
Having a much easier
way of specifying
how your transformation is
providing a visual environment
to [INAUDIBLE],, then you don't
have to write a lot of code
and then manage it and
then just evolve it
over a period of time.
But having a standardized
way of doing that
is extremely important.
And this allows customers to
have faster time to insights.
Now because it's
a standardized way
of specifying transformations
in a visual environment
for providing all of
the transformations as
[INAUDIBLE] to change things
that are required for movement
of the data.
And operationally, it provides
a standard [INAUDIBLE] way
for monitoring these things.
It provides lower [INAUDIBLE].
And because of its simplicity,
you don't have to be an expert.
You don't have to understand
[INAUDIBLE] to actually go
ahead and use this tool.
It does provides
wider accessibility.
Now a lot of business
analysts or data analysts
can actually use this tool to
apply and move transformations
and move the data around
in their organization
for their business reporting
or analytics leads.
Because of the
ability to, again--
the simplicity that it provides.
I would say simplicity
that it provides and also
the consistency in
[INAUDIBLE] that it provides
in terms of how you
actually move data around,
how you do data manipulation and
standardization and cleansing.
It provides
operational efficiency.
And the best part of any
data integration solution
is while you are
in at point A, you
are in a development
environment.
You're developing the pipeline
or designing the pipeline.
Immediately, you can
think what you have build
and translate that
operationally,
being able to run that in
a production environment.
And being able to monitor
that in a consistent way helps
the DevOps team--
DevOps teams have to just
once what they need to do.
And they're able to take all
of that, the learnings from one
set of pipeline, and
apply the same thing
to other pipeline that get
developed as part of this.
Now because an integration
tool talks to a lot of systems,
whether it's systems
or sources or formats.
It doesn't matter.
They're able to capture
a lot of metadata.
And that metadata--
whether it is technical,
business, and
operational metadata--
is extremely important.
And it provides a lot of
insights into the data.
And these are some
of the benefits
that data integration
basically enables.
Without these, it
becomes very hard
when you are actually looking
to move, migrate, and evolve
the data strategy that you
have within your organization.
But none of these, when you
look at the traditional view
and the benefits that
these tools provide,
with the new era, cloud
era, you are actually
seeing a lot more challenges.
In the current world, you're
And these challenges can be
classified into three parts.
One is the growing data assets.
You're all aware.
There is more data everywhere.
You're not able to actually get
a handle on all of the data.
If you are getting
access to that data,
you just don't know
how we can bring them
all together to
further your analytics
or for your business reporting.
It's very hard.
You would have to
do ad hoc one time
at point-to-point integrations.
Whether you're doing it
manually, do it yourself,
it doesn't matter.
The whole idea here is it takes
a lot of effort to do that.
And as the data assets
grow exponentially,
it makes it extremely
difficult to bring data
from various different
silos, or environments,
into one single place.
That's a huge
challenge right now.
Now adding to that challenge is
the complexity of environments.
Now we were talking about--
before, we used to talk
about everything being
on-prem behind the firewall.
Life is good.
But now, it's not the case.
You have on-prem.
You have your own data centers.
Then you have private cloud.
And then you have public clouds.
Now the public
cloud's coming in.
Not everything can
move in the public.
You have hybrid.
And people also adopt
multiple clouds.
So there's some data in cloud
A, some data in cloud B.
So your data assets
are spread across.
Now the complexity
is, how do you
manage data that's spread across
various different environments.
It's extremely difficult.
You use five different tools.
Or you choose to basically do
it all by yourself individually
for each of these environments.
It's just
incomprehensible for you
to basically take
all of these things
and bring them
together seamlessly.
So this is essentially
leading to a lot more problems
and challenges from a data
integration perspective.
And these are some of the
things that traditionally
data integration tools
have to solve for now.
The last one is because
there is so much data
that is being ingested,
there's a lot more metadata
that's being aggregated.
All of the metadata
that is being aggregated
is passive right now.
There is no intelligence
based on that amount of data
to actually leverage
that metadata
to make better decisions of
building smarter pipelines.
So essentially, figuring
out how to execute
in a much better way.
All of these type of
things are something
that the traditional
view misses.
Now that we have looked at
what a traditional view is,
what are the benefits of having
a data integration solution--
and when we look at the
challenges that it presents,
what should a North
Star data integration
solution should look like?
It's very simple.
I have simplified this picture
into-- there are so many
different aspects of it.
But I have tried
simplifying and tried
to focus on core
components that need
to be existing in
a data integration
solution for future.
So this is where we
are headed towards--
first of all, any data
integration solution
should basically support
different environments
that it can run on,
whether it's hybrid,
multicloud, whether it's GCP.
It doesn't matter.
It should be able to
support seamlessly running
on all these environments.
Second, it should
have seamless ability
for aggregating metadata from
various different sources.
So from all the sources
that it interacts with,
it has to aggregate all
of that metadata without--
it should be hassle free.
It should not be someone has
to spend a huge amount of time
to bring that data in.
Once the metadata comes in, the
metadata has to be activated.
[INAUDIBLE] activating
that data that means we
are essentially gathering
insights from that metadata,
understanding how different
entities and the semantics
and the relationships exist.
Understand more in depth
about the characteristics
of the data.
Once you know more about it,
[INAUDIBLE] activated metadata
in terms of automating
integrations.
So you will then have
recommendations probably.
You will make changes to it.
In terms of assisting the
development of the pipelines
that the are building, actually,
all those types of things
become extremely important.
And the one thing
that you will always
think about, from a
North Star perspective,
from a data
integration solution,
is the ability to orchestrate.
So orchestration
is a complex piece.
And when you think about
orchestration, It's.
Not just about
orchestration or pipelines.
So there are several
different components
that need to be orchestrated
that are really important.
And that is something the
orchestration capability
needs to be providing.
In addition to that,
the most important--
and also one of the
important things
from our perspective
of manageability--
is data operations,
having the ability
to manage the pipelines,
understanding the SLAs,
ability to monitor
them constantly
is extremely important.
So when you think about it from
all of these capabilities that
needs to be existing in
our ideal data integration
solution, you can think
about this being a more
integrated platform.
With comprehensive
set of capabilities,
whether you are
actually moving data
in bulk, batch, real time, or
streaming, it doesn't matter.
It also has to
provide deep transfer
smart transformational
capabilities.
It should support
replicating data, whether--
in real-time replication
or batch replication.
Or it's basically snapshotted.
But the ability to
do that in chunks,
those will always be supported.
And most importantly, a
data integration solution
should provide the ability to
improve the quality of the data
as you basically go into
the integration process.
It should not be that
integration process, actually,
reduces the quality of the data.
It should actually make
it easy for improving
the quality of the data.
And that's something
that we believe
at North Star, a hypothetical
data integration solution,
should be providing.
So now that we have looked at
what are the key things that
need to be existing in the North
Star data integration solution,
let's compare that with
what we have in GCP.
And while we have all
of the ingredients,
there are a lot of
missing pieces too.
And we'll talk about
what we have today
and where we want to see,
in the future, the data
integration to [INAUDIBLE].
So what do we have?
We have five or six components
that are already available.
Let's go through them first.
It's one is Data Catalog.
And it's basically
a simple catalog
for storing all of the metadata.
Then you have Composer,
which provides the workflow
management.
You have Fusion, which
is the integration
solution or service.
Then you have Dataflow
and Data Processing,
which are essentially
transformational engines that
are used for
processing your data.
And then you have
Dataprep, which
is [INAUDIBLE]
Trifecta, which provides
the [INAUDIBLE] capability.
So these are all six
components, six services
that have integral part of
an integration solution.
So we look at some of
the capabilities that
exist across all of these that
will enable us to have a better
integration--
a good integration
solution on GCP.
So let's dive
deeper to understand
what are the different
capabilities that we have here.
So first, in order to
have data integration
for optimized
analytics, you need
to be able to have
faster time to insight.
And what does that mean?
Ability to support broad set
of connectors and formats.
I should be able to extract
data from databases,
SAS sources, cloud,
even mainframes,
various different components.
We should be able to
pull that data in.
And not only that, but
we are able to connect
to various different
source systems.
You should also
be able to support
various different formats.
So you should have JSON, CSV,
XML, HL7, those kind of things.
[INAUDIBLE] the next thing
is, for our data integration
solution-- so we do have in
Data Fusion the ability to have
a code-free environment--
and with code.
So you can write code, or
you don't need to write code.
So you can build
the transformations
and prepare all your
data without having
to write any code.
Just with your mouse,
you'll be able to bring data
from various different
sources, transform it
without having to
absolutely write any code.
Now once you write
this code, the thing
is, you need to have the
ability to [INAUDIBLE]..
While you're doing
functional tests,
you are trying to understand
whether the logic that you
have built is actually
working as expected.
Ability to push the system
into a previous state
where you can look at and
process parts of the data
to get a better understanding
of the functionality,
whether it that has to, as
per your requirements or not,
it's [INAUDIBLE].
A functional test capability is
being provided as part of it.
So operationally, I mean--
and from a CI/CD
perspective, you
should be still able to
support taking the pipelines
that you have built and be
able to take all of that stuff
and push it into a
CI/CD environment
so that you can run automated
tests as part of it.
So blending data from
various different sources--
extremely important.
So with Data Fusion,
as an example,
it allows you to bring data
from various different sources.
Whether you're bringing
data from RDBMS, warehouses,
SAS sources, cloud,
mainframes, it doesn't matter,
there are 200-plus
connectors that
exist right now in
Data Fusion that allows
you to bring this data in.
Now all of this data
can be processed using
various different systems.
Data Fusion can basically
allow you to do that.
But you can also use Dataproc.
You can also use BigQuery.
You can also use Dataflow.
So Data Fusion, right now
when you think about it,
from a processing
perspective, actually,
it runs on DataProc, actually.
So it basically uses DataProc
as a processing engine
or a transformation engine.
But in the future, it will
also use BigQuery and Dataflow
[INAUDIBLE] all of these stuff.
But [INAUDIBLE],, as part of
the integration solution,
you have the ability to ingest
data from all of these sources,
bringing that into
GCP seamlessly.
So in order to accelerate
transformations for analytics,
one of the important things
is the data delivery modes.
Can we deliver the data in bulk,
batch, and a streaming fashion?
Yes, of course, we can do that.
So let's talk about Data Fusion.
Data Fusion basically
allows you to--
provides a delivery mode in bulk
and batch and also streaming.
Most of these actually
run on DataProc.
So if you are using
batch, it's [INAUDIBLE]
running in batch mode.
If it is [INAUDIBLE] it's
using Spark streaming.
And in addition to that, you
can of course use DataProc.
And DataProc provides
similar capabilities.
But you will just not have
the top-level environment,
which makes it easy for defining
all of these transformations.
But you can, of course,
try [INAUDIBLE] in DataProc
to be able to do that.
The same thing exists from
a Dataflow perspective.
Dataflow has Dataflow
templates, if you
want to use as a
low-test environment
to define these things.
But you can also use Dataflow
bare bone with its own APIs
to be able to apply all of these
transformations as part of it.
Now the interesting part of
this is, Dataflow is actually
really good about streaming.
So it provides amazing
streaming capabilities
to be able to pull all of the
data in a streaming fashion,
do analysis on it, and be
able to write that, either
into BigQuery or any other
targets that exist on GCP.
Now Data Fusion is
the only component
that provides the
visual environment
for composing the pipelines.
It basically provides an
easy-to-use interface,
which allows you to cleanse,
transform, standardize,
canonicalize, [INAUDIBLE],,
aggregate, join, group by.
Such transformations
can be easily composed
within Data Fusion.
Now across all of
the tools, services
that I talked about--
no, sorry, tools--
services that I
talked about, that
is the ability for gathering
operational insights.
Based on the pipelines
that you run,
there are a lot of
different metrics
that are gathered at
various different stages.
Data Fusion will provide that.
Dataflow also provides that.
So there is an
operational dashboard
that can be looked at
in order to understand
the performance of the pipeline
and tune them [INAUDIBLE]
the processing over
a period of time.
So some of these things
are available as part of it
out of the box.
So like I talked about,
while Data Fusion
can be used from an
integration perspective,
all of the processing
still happens on DataProc.
But DataProc and Dataflow
can be used independently
for building some of
these capabilities,
if you would like to have
the nonvisual environment.
So they act as a transformation
engine of the Data Fusion.
But they can be
used independently
for even doing the same tasks.
So the main thing, the one
point that I want to make clear,
is we have the capability
right now to turn Data Fusion
pipelines into DataProc.
The capability for running
it on Dataflow doesn't exist.
So if you are
invested and if you
would like to see Dataflow
integration happening with Data
Fusion, please do send us.
And let's talk.
And let's talk further about
the use case that you have
and how we can
essentially help you.
Would love to get a lot
more feedback on this.
So please do let us
know as soon as you can.
And for orchestration
perspective, of course,
our Composer is the best.
And it allows you to orchestrate
not only just the Data Fusion
pipelines.
But you can
orchestrate pipelines
and various different things.
So from that, one thing to note
is there's a better integration
between Composer and
Dataflow-- sorry--
Data Fusion right now.
So Composer workflows
have actions now
that will allow you to
deploy, trigger, start, stop,
those kind of things.
Do the lifecycle management of
the pipelines for Data Fusion.
So let's talk about metadata.
So like I talked
about it before,
metadata plays a very vital
role in the next generation data
integration solution.
Right now, the difference
between what exists today
and what we need to
shoot for tomorrow
is the activating the
metadata that we have exists,
currently existing.
There's a lot of metadata
that's collected.
It's just sitting there.
People can look at it.
They feel good about
that they have metadata.
But there is nothing
else more than
that we are actually
doing with that metadata.
So the next generation
data integration solution
should be taking all
of that metadata,
looking at it from
the different lens,
and using that information for
building better integration
solutions.
So the first thing, the first
step for doing all of that
is the ability to capture all
of that metadata automatically.
Ability of capturing
technical business
and operational metadata--
and business metadata
might be a little bit difficult
because business metadata
requires you to have a good
understanding of the business.
But [INAUDIBLE] technical
and operational metadata
can be automatically
captured as part of it.
Now once you have
captured that metadata,
the ability to take an
end-to-end view of that
metadata, of the data--
so looking at the
metadata, you are
able to construct an
end-to-end view of it.
You are able to understand
the data model better.
You are able to profile
the data and get a better
understanding of that data.
All of that plays
a very vital role
in establishing various
different relationships that
can exist between the data sets.
So this is something
that is important
and that needs to be captured.
And we do that today.
So as part of Data Fusion, we
automatically build a pipeline.
All metadata gets
captured automatically.
When you essentially
a query in BigQuery,
that metadata gets captured
into Data Catalog seamlessly.
The third part of
this is I don't--
in a real world, there will
be multiple data catalogs.
I don't think we
can ever say there
will be one single catalog
that everyone [INAUDIBLE]..
I would love to
have that vision.
And I know whoever the wants
that central data catalog will
actually own the data at least.
But the biggest benefit
that the customers
will have with having a
centralized data catalog
is the ability to optimize
their processing for cost,
for execution, for SLAs,
for even identifying
the best tool or best workload
and basically the best
tool for that workload.
So having that
ability is important.
So now the thing is, in order
to support that kind of vision,
you need to have the ability to
exchange data between catalogs.
So there needs to be a
standard formats of exchange.
Or we need to expose APIs.
And we do.
Data Catalog does.
[INAUDIBLE] catalog also
exposes that metadata out
for the consumer.
But to be told, there is a lot
more work to be done there.
But it does have an
API, which can be used.
But it's not very
comprehensive here,
from a Data Fusion perspective.
So for people who don't know
what Data Catalog is, just
to give a recap on it, Data
Catalog is a catalog solution.
It's a metadata
system, which allows
you to discover, manage, and
understand your data assets.
So it's basically
provides the ability
to index all of the
metadata that is aggregated
and provides a discoverability,
like search capability,
where you can search
it based on the labels.
Or you can search it based
on the name, description.
It also includes a free
text search as part of it.
It's a foundational
layer for [INAUDIBLE]..
It's integrated with DLP.
And it's integrated with IAM.
And for people who
don't know DLP,
it's the data loss
prevention, which allows
you to tag sensitive data.
And then all that
sensitive data that
gets tagged gets
[INAUDIBLE] up in Data
Catalog, which can be then-- a
proper action can be associated
with it once that particular
sensitive data has been
identified from Data Catalog.
Next, there is no
discussion that
ever happens about
metadata which it does not
involve data lineage.
And data lineage is
a critical aspect
of data integration solution.
And one of the main reasons
for that is our customers
would like to understand
the flow of the data.
They would like
to understand how
the data that is being prepared
for business was generated.
Because if the
business decisions
are based on the final
analytics data that was created,
they would like to understand
how that data was generated.
[INAUDIBLE] purposes from
compliance purposes, this
is an essential and
a critical component
that any data
integration solution
should be able to support.
Now what does data
lineage provide?
It provides a
granular visibility
into the flow of the data.
When you look at this particular
picture here, if you see,
there are a lot of different
fine-grained details
that are being provided.
It's the individual field level.
The data is being captured.
When you look at an
individual field,
you have to understand
where it came from.
You'll also have to understand
where it is going towards.
So what is the
downstream processing
that it actually even be doing?
Now when you think about
it from that perspective,
this also allows you to have
more of an operational view.
So you are able to look
at it and say, you know,
this particular data was created
from these three different data
sets.
And these are the few things
that we have transformed
in order to create this
individual field that
exists in the target data set.
And that is something that
has to be captured seamlessly,
without any human intervention.
They have to be cataloged.
They have to be presented as
a fact and then visualized.
And this is something that is
being provided out of the box
as part of the Data Fusion.
So lineage also
allows you to have
things like root cause analysis,
impact analysis, provenance.
All of these kind
of things comes out
of the box from
that perspective.
And as part of a
data integration
solution, [INAUDIBLE].
And I have seen, and I
heard a customer says that.
[INAUDIBLE] can be
a separate solution.
But it doesn't matter because
the only way while you
will generally see that lineage
is attached from an integration
perspective is because
integration solutions allow
you to capture the
transformations
in a standard form, that you
are combining two columns
or creating 10 columns
or filtering data.
These standard
operations, essentially,
have to be captured
in the standard way.
And then they can be associated
with every individual field
that exists as part of
the integration process.
And then be able to visualize
them seamlessly as part of it.
So you get a full depth here.
You cannot just take any
data, write it in a C code,
and then say, oh,
show me the lineage.
It doesn't come for free.
But there needs to
be done something--
APIs that are provided
that basically
have to be used for capturing
the metadata of the operations
that they put.
So think of it this way.
You would have to
write the documentation
for the operations
that you are doing.
And then you have to
do the operations.
That's exactly what
needs to be happening
if you are not using--
and like an integration solution
or a structured environment.
And SQL is a very
structured environment.
So that's fine.
But being able to do it
in an ad hoc environment
is extremely complex for humans.
Next thing that is important is
openness, or ability to share
[INAUDIBLE].
Like I said,
catalog-to-catalog exchange
is going to become more common.
But I don't believe we'll have
one catalog that basically
collects everything,
which is totally
possible in one environment.
But different choices, different
customer requirements--
you might end up in a situation
where you will have to share.
So with the Data Catalog, you
can use the APIs to do that.
With Data Fusion, you can
similarly use APIs to do that.
And Data Fusion APIs allows
you to extract [INAUDIBLE]..
Data consistency--
very important.
You have to be confident
in the decisions
that you are making for your
business based on the data
that you have integrated.
So the first thing
you have to ensure
is when someone builds data
quality rules or someone
doing the transformations,
we are making
it hard to make mistakes.
So you have to have
the ability to--
with existing,
predefined directives
and things that exist, it
just makes it extremely
easy for defining that.
The next is ability
to profile data
and identifying quality issues.
In Data Fusion right
now, you have a profiler
that you can include
in the pipeline that
allows you to extract a
lot of different metadata
that exists in--
ability to extract a lot
of metrics from the data.
So it can help identify
whether the data is--
there is categorical
data that has
a lot of different metrics,
quantitative data, and then
Boolean.
So you can essentially look
at different statistics
being generated for
different categories of data.
And then you can investigate
that to make better decisions
based on the
statistics of the data.
So you can at least help
identify the problems
if there are any issues.
Handling data drifts--
nothing is constant.
Things keep changing.
Data sets evolve.
So things get added.
Things get subtracted.
Things get modified.
So ability to first
detect those changes
that happen in the system.
Next-- ability to
take actions on them
is critically important.
With Data Fusion, we do provide
some of the capabilities
in handling data drift.
We are able to identify them.
And we can take certain actions.
Either you can drop
them, or essentially you
can filter them off.
But the thing that we don't
have yet is being able to--
I mean, I wouldn't say that yet.
But the ability to apply
the changes on the target
is not consistently available
across different components
of it.
It always depends
on the target system
to which this may be applied.
So it is a case-by-case basis,
at least from a Data Fusion
perspective.
And when you're talking about
in a Dataflow or DataProc,
you will have to implement
that [INAUDIBLE]..
The next piece is
open, and hybrid,
and multicloud environment.
We believe in GCP that
having the ability
to take our integration
solution and moving that
into [INAUDIBLE] should
give you [INAUDIBLE],,
should give customers
the [INAUDIBLE]..
Having that ability to
do that exists today.
Frankly, if you look
at it, Data Fusion
is based on CDAP open
source, which came from Cask.
So that allows you to
actually run it on-prem.
You can run it on-prem.
You run it on another cloud.
When you think about it
from a Composer perspective,
it's based on Airflow.
So you can run Airflow on-prem.
I'm not saying that this is
the best way of doing it.
By next, we'll have more news
on what we are doing there.
But the whole idea
here is you today
have the ability to run
them in these environments.
So you can deploy them in a
hybrid environment, another
[INAUDIBLE].
And when you think about it from
a Dataflow perspective, which
provides streaming
capabilities, you
have Apache Beam as an
[INAUDIBLE] and open source.
And you can use
that in [INAUDIBLE]..
Data protection-- this is
one of the important aspects
of an integration solution.
Securing the keys is the ability
to store the keys in a secured
fashion because there are many
aspects of data integration
that have to be stored
in a secured manner,
whether it's
passwords, auth tokens,
all these cannot be in plaintext
field within your pipeline.
So you would have to
store them in the KMS.
And when you run a job, the
people with the right access
will have the permissions
to extract those keys
and be able to run that job.
So all of the solutions
integrate with KMS.
The ability to mask,
redact, and encrypt
is critically important.
You might think of--
we are not talking here
about masking, redacting,
and encrypting all of the data
and all components of the data.
Here, having the ability
to uniquely identify
certain sensitive fields,
be able to mask them,
redact them, or encrypt them
is a great capability to have.
And any integration
solution should
be able to provide that
kind of capability.
Now for GCP, we have one of
the best technologies that
is available through DLP that
provides us ability to mask,
redact, and encrypt.
So Data Fusion is
integrated with the DLP.
A few configurations,
and off you go.
You are able to encrypt
all of your data.
You can redact it or encrypt it.
You can do the same thing
with Dataflow and as well
as DataProc.
We take standards and
compliance as they
are the most important
thing for us.
Data protection is the most
important thing for overall,
for GCP.
But we spend a
huge amount of time
in ensuring that we
[INAUDIBLE] to the industry
standards for data
protection policies
and be compliant with it.
HIPAA, PCI/DSS, [INAUDIBLE]----
these are some of the things,
from a compliance perspective,
that we [INAUDIBLE]..
And there's a long
list of things
that we basically
are in compliant of.
Now when you look at it from
a data protection perspective,
then you want to ingest
data from an on-prem system.
You need to have the ability
to have access to that data.
So in which case, you
don't want to expose
all of your internal
systems to the cloud.
You want to have much
more fine-grained control
of these type of things.
With Private IP, we do support
those kind of capability,
where you can expose
within [INAUDIBLE],,
within your IP range, you can
basically give access to that.
Ability to encrypt
data at rest--
when you think about it
from that perspective,
we need to have--
you're going to use the
customer-managed encryptions
key.
Any of these tools
should basically,
as part of an
integration solution,
should provide you the ability
to pass on the information,
or the encryption key
that is being provided,
to the underlying storage
system where the data actually
get stored.
And it's encrypted
using the key that has
been specified by the customer.
In addition to that,
the data exfiltration
process-- it's a protection,
which is extremely important.
You want certain regions
or certain regions
within the [INAUDIBLE]
data that it should reside.
So you're going to use VPC
controls [INAUDIBLE] parameters
around that.
That will allow you to
protect the region in which
the data should be residing.
And all of these
services that I talked--
Data Fusion, Dataflow,
DataProc-- all
provide that kind of capability.
Now putting it all together,
here's the interesting thing.
We talked about various
different services,
various different
capabilities that exist.
They need to be all put
together into a single account.
And this is where the
Data Fusion activity
is going to shape itself into.
Where you will have
the ability, when
we bring all of the capabilities
that we talked about,
bar from Data Catalog.
We talked about DataProc,
Dataflow, such kind of things.
And push them into Data
Fusion as the face for it.
While you can use all
of these capabilities
individually, but from a
data integration solution,
we are essentially bringing them
all together into this piece.
So they're all the things
we'll be integration.
So when you think about it
just from a future perspective,
you will have--
we already run it on DataProc.
We already run on [INAUDIBLE].
So [INAUDIBLE] integrate
with BigQuery and Dataflow.
So the whole idea
here is depending
on the pipeline,
the characteristics
of the pipeline,
and the data that
is associated with
the pipeline, you
need to be able to
pick which environment
or which transformation
engine should
be used for processing that
segment up the pipeline.
That basically can be providing
cost optimization [INAUDIBLE]
optimization.
These are the two things that
would be exposed to the user
so that they can control it.
Of course, as a
user, you wouldn't
need to have the
ability to choose that.
You would want to have this
engine to be the default.
And you want to run an
entire pipeline for this.
But having that ability
is extremely important.
So that's one place where
we basically bring that all
into this canvas.
The second is, like
I talked about,
metadata will play
a very vital role.
So we will be
integrating, looking
at integrating with
Data Catalog because it
becomes a critical piece
from an integration solution
perspective.
You need to bring all of the
metadata that exists there
as well as be able to
exchange the metadata that
exists in the CBF catalog
with the Data Catalog.
So they will be
working in conjunction
to essentially activate
that metadata so that we
can do better integrations,
provide smart mapping
capabilities, provide the
ability to recommendations
for things that have to
be defined from a pipeline
perspective, or
transformation perspective,
or standardization perspective.
So all that gets put together
in a much more coherent way
as part of [INAUDIBLE].
So this is one thing that
I wanted to talk about.
And I know many customers
have asked about it.
And you might be
already wondering
because we talked about
it in the previous Next.
Replicator-- it is basically
a [INAUDIBLE] solution
that basically we're working
towards as part of Data Fusion.
So this is something that will
be available in Data Fusion.
It's a new Data Fusion addon.
We have introduced
these concepts
of addon, which really can have
a single Data Fusion instance
and add these on top
of it to accelerate
the replication of data at
low latency in real time
from operational
databases and to BigQuery.
So we will be only
supporting target
as a BigQuery for this year.
But in the future,
we'll be changing
that to include other
topics, too, as part of it.
So it's a log-based replication.
So it will support
different sources.
And as we come closer,
we can talk [INAUDIBLE]..
If there are certain sources
that you are interested in,
please do come talk to us.
We'll be more than happy
to understand your use case
and prioritize that for you.
So with that, I
think we have covered
a lot of different aspects
of data integration.
And I think I would like to
basically leave you with,
where we are seeing
in the future
and where we would be
heading in the future?
When you combine all of those
different aspects that we
talked about for an ideal data
integration solution to exist--
this picture looks complex,
which actually is not.
When you think about what
is the most important thing.
[INAUDIBLE] we'll
always have data sources
that will be coming from
various different aspects
of the organization and
various different systems.
That will generate
a lot of metadata.
There are different
metadata types--
technical, operational,
business, social, quality.
There are a lot of
different metadata types
that we'll be generating.
Right now, all that metadata
that exists in systems.
It exists in Catalog.
It exists in Data
Fusion catalog.
But all of that metadata
is providing definition
for different entities, this
semantic meaning for it.
And they are providing
relationships
with different data assets.
All of that is
passive right now.
So you can take that and turn it
into an active metadata, where
you activate that metadata.
You basically use AI-ML method
to generate more insight.
I'm abstracting here.
I'm not trying to
get deeper into this.
But you'll be able to
extract a lot of information
from that method, which
we have actually seen it.
It brings in a huge amount
of information from it.
You look at the
operational metadata.
You can essentially
look at different ways
of optimizing your pipelines.
You look at the utilization.
You look at data quality.
You get a lot of
different aspects
that basically
come with metadata.
All this can then be pushed
in from a smart integration
perspective, which
will be, again,
which will be
[INAUDIBLE] automated
with the active metadata.
So all that stuff gets combined
together in such a way.
Like I talked about,
adaptive execution,
that plays a very wide role
in the next generation, which
is going to be [INAUDIBLE].
And Data Fusion is ability
to run across these engines.
So as a customer, you should
not be worrying about where
actually your pipeline runs.
Of course, you would
need to have controls
in SLA and [INAUDIBLE].
But rest all should be
taken care by automatically.
Whether you run it
on-prem, whether you run it
on cloud, where you run
it, it shouldn't matter.
That's point A. Point B--
the parts of the pipeline
should be able to select
the best engine that it
should be running on.
So all that combined
together provides
an active, adaptive
execution environment.
And on top of that, we have
to have the best orchestration
typically that allows not
only just the Data Fusion
pipelines but also going
wide across the [INAUDIBLE]
for supporting the end-to-end
data integration needs.
In addition to that, when I look
at the data operation security
compliance, there's
pretty much table states.
And the solutions on
top should basically
start provide
[INAUDIBLE] for retail,
for finance, for telcos,
for different industries.
We should be able to have
people solutions that
basically come out of the
box for our customers to use.
So this is the view on the
future of how data integration
would evolve into.
And this is how Data Fusion
would evolve into, too.
That's all.
If you guys have
any questions, I'll
be more than happy to take them.
Thank you for your time.